the disease won't find much resistance
and will begin spreading from person to person,
and in no time it will disseminate throughout the community.
After a certain time
a big part of the population will be ill.
This happened when there were no vaccines.
Now, imagine the complete opposite case.
We are in a city
where more than 90 percent of the population
has defenses against the measles, which means
that they either had the disease, survived, and developed natural defenses;
or that they had been immunized against measles.
If one day,
a person sick with the measles appears in this city,
the disease will find much more resistance
and won't be transmitted that much from person to person.
The spread will probably remain contained
and a measles outbreak won't happen.
I would like you to pay attention to something.
People who are vaccinated
are not only protecting themselves,
but by blocking the dissemination of the disease
within the community,
they are indirectly protecting the people in this community
who are not vaccinated.
They create a kind of protective shield
which prevents them from coming in contact with the disease,
so that these people are protected.
This indirect protection
that the unvaccinated people within a community receive
simply by being surrounded by vaccinated people,
is called herd immunity.
Many people in the community
depend almost exclusively on this herd immunity
to be protected against disease.
The unvaccinated people you see in infographics are not just hypothetical.
Those people are our nieces and nephews, our children,
who may be too young to receive their first shots.
They are our parents, our siblings,
our acquaintances,
who may have a disease,
or take medication that lowers their defenses.
There are also people who are allergic to a particular vaccine.
They could even be among us,
any of us who got vaccinated,
but the vaccine didn't produce the expected effect,
because not all vaccines are always 100 percent effective.
All these people depend almost exclusively on herd immunity
to be protected against diseases.
To achieve this effect of herd immunity,
it is necessary that a large percentage of the population be vaccinated.
This percentage is called the threshold.
The threshold depends on many variables:
It depends on the germ's characteristics,
and those of the immune response that the vaccine generates.
But they all have something in common.
If the percentage of the population in a vaccinated community
is below this threshold number,
the disease will begin to spread more freely
and may generate an outbreak of this disease within the community.
Even diseases which were at some point controlled may reappear.
This is not just a theory.
This has happened, and is still happening.
In 1998, a British researcher published an article
in one of the most important medical journals,
saying that the MMR vaccine,
which is given for measles, mumps and rubella,
was associated with autism.
This generated an immediate impact.
People began to stop getting vaccinated, and stopped vaccinating their children.
And what happened?
The number of people vaccinated,
in many communities around the world, fell below this threshold.
And there were outbreaks of measles in many cities in the world --
in the U.S., in Europe.
Many people got sick.
People died of measles.
What happened?
This article also generated a huge stir within the medical community.
Dozens of researchers began to assess if this was actually true.
Not only could no one find
a causal association between MMR and autism at the population level,
but it was also found that this article had incorrect claims.
Even more, it was fraudulent.
It was fraudulent.
In fact, the journal publicly retracted the article in 2010.
One of the main concerns and excuses for not getting vaccinated
are the adverse effects.
Vaccines, like other drugs, can have potential adverse effects.
Most are mild and temporary.
But the benefits are always greater than possible complications.
When we are ill, we want to heal fast.
Many of us who are here
take antibiotics when we have an infection,
we take anti-hypertensives when we have high blood pressure,
we take cardiac medications.
Why? Because we are sick and we want to heal fast.
And we don't question it much.
Why is it so difficult to think of preventing diseases,
by taking care of ourselves when we are healthy?
We take care of ourselves a lot when affected by an illness,
or in situations of imminent danger.
I imagine most of us here,
remember the influenza-A pandemic
which broke out in 2009 in Argentina and worldwide.
When the first cases began to come to light,
we, here in Argentina, were entering the winter season.
We knew absolutely nothing.
Everything was a mess.
People wore masks on the street, ran into pharmacies to buy alcohol gel.
People would line up in pharmacies to get a vaccine,
without even knowing if it was the right vaccine
that would protect them against this new virus.
We knew absolutely nothing.
At that time, in addition to doing my fellowship at the Infant Foundation,
I worked as a home pediatrician for a prepaid medicine company.
I remember that I started my shift at 8 a.m.,
and by 8, I already had a list of 50 scheduled visits.
It was chaos; people didn't know what to do.
I remember the types of patients that I was examining.
The patients were a little older than what we were used to seeing in winter,
with longer fevers.
And I mentioned that to my fellowship mentor,
and he, for his part, had heard the same from a colleague,
about the large number of pregnant women
and young adults
being hospitalized in intensive care,
with hard-to-manage clinical profiles.
At that time, we set out to understand what was happening.
First thing Monday morning, we took the car
and went to a hospital in Buenos Aires Province,
that served as a referral hospital for cases of the new influenza virus.
We arrived at the hospital; it was crowded.
All health staff were dressed in NASA-like bio-safety suits.
We all had face masks in our pockets.
I, being a hypochondriac, didn't breathe for two hours.
But we could see what was happening.
Immediately, we started reaching out to pediatricians
from six hospitals in the city and in Buenos Aires Province.
Our main goal was to find out
how this new virus behaved in contact with our children,
in the shortest time possible.
A marathon work.
In less than three months,
we could see what effect this new H1N1 virus had
on the 251 children hospitalized by this virus.
We could see which children got more seriously ill:
children under four, especially those less than one year old;
patients with neurological diseases;
and young children with chronic pulmonary diseases.
Identifying these at-risk groups was important
to include them as priority groups
in the recommendations for getting the influenza vaccine,
not only here in Argentina,
but also in other countries which the pandemic not yet reached.
A year later,
when a vaccine against the pandemic H1N1 virus became available,
we wanted to see what happened.
After a huge vaccination campaign
aimed at protecting at-risk groups,
these hospitals, with 93 percent of the at-risk groups vaccinated,
had not hospitalized a single patient
for the pandemic H1N1 virus.
(Applause)
In 2009: 251.
In 2010: zero.
Vaccination is an act of individual responsibility,
but it has a huge collective impact.
If I get vaccinated, not only am I protecting myself,
but I am also protecting others.
Sol had whooping cough.
Sol was very young,
and she hadn't yet received her first vaccine against whooping cough.
I still wonder what would have happened
if everyone around Sol had been vaccinated.
(Applause)